now so um yeah  the the h pawn i expect will hurry up  your favorite child simon  so was a good one  it was a good move that one said harry  that will become a queen  yeah that one on gary yeah harry or yeah  or alice on the other side of the board  waiting near the white king the problem  is black's defenses are just going to be  stretched so any or maybe even all of  the pawns will become queens  yeah  it's difficult but i like what  christopher is doing despite a hopeless  situation he's still battling on yeah  never resign in rapid chess  hans could get disconnected  yeah he might blunder i might mouse slip  there's always a tiny little sliver of  hope  more  okay attacking white's bishop but this  check  is going to be the killer  king is going to move and the white  pawns are going to promote yeah there we  go hans takes another one  another win for hans niemann two out of  two wins so far in the julius bear